as a new Clipper what product do you
think I should everything you should be
laying in bed at night searching like
hats how do you think I figured out mug
life I was like I see a lot of mugs at
garage sales do mugs sell for anything
search on eBay mugs holy there's 88
mugs there's 63 mugs there's 96 mugs
then go buy a bunch of bugs for a
quarter come home look them up educate
educate educate the key to flip life is
the homework you do at night during the
week that you then leverage on
Saturday when you kill it with your
knowledge but I don't know where
it even to go like where do I start
I'm gonna show you eBay right
now you're going to garage sales you're
like oh I see a lot of salt and
pepper shakers then you go to filter
sold and completed items store highest
price and then you're like oh 441
600 a thousand who bought this salt and
pepper shaker collectors why
would people buy speakers for 500 they
collect them why do people buy shirts
they collect them people buy everything
everything could be flipped